Get the popcorn out he's gonna do a speech
see what's happening here you're afraid
i'm scared oh oh no
anxious
my friends times like this we need
to unite come together i'm sorry me
it's very hard to get a rousing speech
with the hate noise oh god we're gonna die
so this is my vow oh god she will die
that seems a bit dangerous this ends here and now
giant goats look at those they are wonderful
yes they are they also scream quite a lot
Welcome back everyone we have a brand new thor
love and thunder trailer video so we'll break
it all down there's a bunch of new easter eggs a
bunch of new footage especially the guardians of
the galaxy so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos because
the movie is going to be dropping really soon
we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets for
the movie all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just post all your predictions
for the movie on the video this trailer mostly
focuses on thor trying to rally everybody in
asgard like forming his new revengers or forming
the revengers 2.0 because it seems like gorr has
already attacked and now he's in the version of
new asgard's town hall or like the throne room
where valkyrie normally holds court and makes all
of her decisions one of the other brand new things
that's actually really cool is omnipotent city
they confirmed that they have omnipotent city in
the movie this is right out of the gorr comics
and i'm wondering if this is actually going to
be a version of just regular omnipotentity or if
they're combining this with some aspects of the
film in the trailers we have all these scenes that
seem like they've been at a version of olympus in
the mcu which seems like it's zeus's version
of asgard in the mcu version of the greek gods
exists kind of like the asgardians do but the
whole thing with omnipotent city in the comics
is that it's actually basically a city of the gods
built by the old gods but in the grand history of
the mcu timeline like you remember the loki series
we saw the entire sacred timeline so you have to
imagine like at the very beginning of that what
you call the elder gods existed like the original
gods of gods like cthone is the god of chaos
he's the person who's responsible for scarlet
witch becoming the scarlet witch getting her chaos
magic when she was born they referenced him with
a darkhold temple during doctor strange too he
is one of the elder gods they're like a race of
gods that existed millions and millions of years
ago but they're not like the original elder gods
there are gods that are even older than that what
happened billions of years ago is that this race
of elder gods fought this god-tier version of
avengers end game with each other and it almost
destroyed all of reality a bunch of them died
off but eventually they called the truce and
to mark their truce they created omnipotent city
which was meant to be a place of fellowship for
all other gods that would eventually come after
them and the way they explain god's being born
or god's being raised up later on in the timeline
is that god's gonna have children they can have
progeny but when they pass their power on the gods
that come after them are a little bit weaker so
gradually over time you have these really really
ancient original elder gods having their children
either dying off passing their power along in the
gods slowly become weaker and weaker and weaker
but over time there are more and more and more of
them they start to proliferate around all these
cultures around the universe so each culture has
their own pantheon of gods eventually well during
the gorr of the god butcher storyline thor winds
up traveling to omnipotent city to try and get
information on all the gods of the universe and
find out what's going on because he learns that
gorr is going after all the gods so omnipotent
city is sort of like this center of information
about all god related things inside the universe
and even though they're changing some of the gorr
storyline for the movie like it's a bit of a speed
run version of the gorr storyline when he goes to
omnipotent city he just finds all this destruction
in his wake and there are a couple gods that
have survived and they kind of inform him what's
going on but now i'm also wondering if when jane
foster goes and sees all the statues of the cosmic
entities i've already done a video about all them
so i'll link it below in the description if that's
happening in omnipotent city because it seems like
that's the place that that would happen like if
they're gonna have a place that's gonna reference
all the most powerful cosmic entities in the
universe it would probably be at omnipotent city
but for instance when they're having their mcu
version of the godhead here which is like all the
most powerful gods all meeting with each other we
thought that it was happening at olympus but this
actually might be happening at omnipotent city so
they might be combining those things in the movie
just to sort of speed run through some of this
plot you see a lot more footage of them attacking
the guards they all seem like they do bleed gold
and i think that is right out of mythology that
the greek gods bleed gold that's why you would
see valkyrie just covered in gold fluid because
she's cutting through all these guards you see all
them standing in the background here just kind of
listening to him jane foster has already become a
version of female thor because this is happening
after gorr's first attack so he's already learned
about the big twist with her getting the power of
mjolnir in it reforming valkyrie also seems like
she's wearing a phantom of the opera t-shirt
which might sort of play into the whole idea
of tourism at new asgard there's the new scene
of meek wearing that animatronic suit so that
he can walk around and just act like a normal
person being an assistant like he's dressed as if
he's some sort of executive assistant to valkyrie
you see he's drawn versions of asgard and mjolnir
here and if you didn't see before on the left
hand frame you can actually see what the guards in
new asgard are wearing now like this is just like
a regular guard these are the new uniforms that
valkyrie has them in they have a really cool scene
of the guardians of the galaxy on a completely
different planet having an adventure this just
probably plays in with the montage early in the
film just to let you know what thor has been doing
this whole time then this shot is just meant to
be like another hero shot early in the film before
thor has lost all the weight like you see them
walking he's got his old armor on and you see
craglin in the background wearing yondu's fin
if you remember at the end of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 yondu had left that to him in his
will basically we'll probably see him doing that
again during guardians of the galaxy vol 3. he
is in guardians of the galaxy 3. you also notice
that groot is still teenage groot i think they've
been saving him becoming like the full-size alpha
version of groot until guardians 3 but i think
when he grows back he will be like the biggest
baddest craziest version you've ever seen of groot
then they just released a brand new featurette
this cage seems like it's attached to this part
of the movie here where you see in the background
this is giant nebula this seems like the movie's
version of gorr's god bomb however they've changed
that part of the comic for the movie it's just
like his plan to speed everything up and kill
all the gods in one fell swoop it's like thanos
going from balancing every single planet one at a
time to using the infinity stones to balance the
entire universe in one fell snap of his fingers
because of the way they're using zeus in the
movie too a lot of you have asked is zeus or
odin more powerful like who is the most
powerful god who's the most powerful pantheon
technically in the comics the way they played
it is that odin with the odin force is meant to
be more powerful than zeus ultimately but the way
the movie's using him i think that they're trying
to hype up zeus like show how powerful he is he
accidentally flicks too hard and they want to show
him flicking like he's barely using any power and
it's still that powerful to help hype up gorr the
god butcher's strength when he eventually rolls in
and kills all these gods or most of these gods i
think we're all in agreement that's why valkyrie
has his lightning bolt because gorr has killed
him or most of his pantheon at least everyone
pour one out for russell crowe zeus i also think
that's why he's so ridiculous like they also want
gorr to feel kind of sympathetic so that you're
cheering him on while he's killing a lot of these
gods because a lot of the mcu gods are terrible
just like a konchu even though they're hiding
in an alternate dimension eventually gorr would
gain enough power to go get them too they also
have all those scenes where chris hemsworth
says that in the movie thor is trying to find his
grand cosmic purpose like he's not sure what he's
oh look they have this funny scene here where he's
sitting under the tree and it seems like mantis